aujourd'hui on était largement dépendant
d'autres pays parce que on n'a pas une
capacité d'énergie pilotable donc ils
m'ont propos n'est pas d'opposer les
énergies nucléaires hydroélectriques
avec l'éolien ou le photovoltaïque sauf
que pour avoir une indépendance
énergétique avoir un prix accessible il
nous faut une énergie une colonne
vertébrale énergétique pilotable et
c'est le nucléaire c'est
l'hydroélectricité de nous on a fait le
choix effectivement d'avoir une énergie
accessible décarbonée
les travaux que j'ai réalisé sur ce
texte a été de confirmer trois trois
éléments en première élément il y a
urgence effectivement à agir et pour
cela il faut mettre en cohérence les
différents textes aujourd'hui on a un
texte de simplification d'accélération
pour construire des réacteurs et on a
parallèlement toujours à cela une
décision qu'on va fermer 14 réacteurs
donc où est la cohérence deuxième point
c'est le seuil de 50%
qui est toujours en vigueur et qui n'a
pas non plus de sens puisque aujourd'hui
on veut ambitionner de
repositionner en France des productions
industrielles donc on veut reproduire
relocaliser dans nos territoires si on
veut reproduire et à développer
l'activité industrielle ce qui est
absolument nécessaire il nous faut de
l'énergie et de l'énergie accessible
accessible pour les considéréens
accessibles pour les collectivités mais
aussi à un prix accessible et une
garantie de fournitures au quotidien
pour les entreprises
premier élément il faut simplifier donc
chaque fois qu'on peut simplifier il
faut le faire pour effectivement aller
plus vite pour qu'on est retrouve cette
capacité de production je rappelle que
pour produire et construire un EPS et
aux alentours de 15 ans toute la partie
administrative doit être
la plus courte possible pour lancer
cette construction il faut aussi se
projeter sur le futur donc il faut
encourager la jeunesse à se réinvestir
dans ces métiers nous avons perdu les
compétences relancer la production la
capacité à produire des des réacteurs
des centrales de nouvelles générations
dans notre territoire c'est c'est 30000
emplois de techniciens d'ingénieurs de
personnes de compétences qui pour
certaines ont disparu donc ça se fait
pas en claquant dans les doigts mais ça
ne se fera que si on a lisibilité de la
stratégie le rôle de du gouvernement le
rôle du Parlement c'est d'être stratège
avoir une vision à l'énergie c'est pas
une politique à court terme l'énergie
c'est quelque chose qui se décline sur
un mi siècle c'est quelque chose qui est
très profond en termes d'action